this episode is made possible by
dashlane protect your valuable data from
prying eyes with a free account from
dashlane when was the last time you
replaced your phone what about your
laptop your razor a light bulb probably
pretty recently
with a product like a light bulb you
replace it out of necessity the bulb
stops working you get a new one
razors are similar once the blade isn't
sharp anymore you throw it out and
replace it laptops and smartphones are a
different story
odds are the last time you bought a new
phone your old one still works just fine
a recent study showed that on average
Americans tend to replace their
smartphones every twenty two point seven
months under two years what's going on
here why do we keep consuming products
at such a rapid rate
short answer many products are designed
to break wear out or become useless in
some other fashion the longer answer is
a bit more nuanced there are two factors
at work planned obsolescence and
perceived obsolescence in a nutshell
planned obsolescence is a strategy that
some manufacturers employ to make sure
their product fails after a certain
amount of time or usage these days
you'll often hear people say things like
they don't make them like they used to
and in some regards that's accurate but
the history of planned obsolescence goes
back further than you think in 1925 when
commercially available lightbulbs were
still relatively new an international
group of companies came together in
Geneva to found the Phoebus cartel these
companies included some we still see
today like General Electric and Philips
among others their idea was simple
restrict the useful life of all
commercially available lightbulbs to
1000 hours thus generating repeat sales
and maximizing profit the Phoebus cartel
slashed bulb life from around 2,500 to
1,000 hours and since these companies
more or less controlled the entire
market they could raise prices without
fear of competition the group demanded
each member company send bulbs for
inspection at their laboratory and any
company whose bulb exceeded the thousand
hour limit was fined based on how far
off they were this shady practice
continued without the public's knowledge
until 1939 when world war ii complicated
international business this is just one
example of corporations conspiring to
maximize profits on products that could
be much more durable or long-lasting
another common example is razors why
sell just one product that a customer
can maintain for years with a little
care
when you can sell them the convenience
of replaceable parts this is where the
two part pricing strategy really came
into the mainstream you could buy a
handle for your razor and instead of
having to keep honing a fixed blade you
could just throw away the old blade and
attach a new one the customer gets a
more convenient shave and the
corporation can keep making money from
that customer for as long as they need
sharp blades multiply that by tens or
hundreds of thousands of customers and
you have an extremely lucrative business
model two part pricing is incredibly
common today look at video game consoles
you buy the console once but the company
profits every time you buy a game you
buy one coffee maker then hundreds of
pods over its lifetime one printer
hundreds or even thousands of dollars in
ink cartridges that last one can be
particularly egregious as many printers
have been shown to stop printing
properly well before their cartridges
are actually out of ink higher-end
examples of planned obsolescence include
TVs with sensitive parts installed near
heat sources sneakily reducing their
effective life and smart phones with non
replaceable batteries which stop holding
a charge after a couple of years planned
obsolescence is only one part of the
picture though what happens when a
product is inherently too reliable to
break every year to cars high-end
smartphones and laptops sound systems
TVs the big-ticket items that should
last you a while because of how
expensive they are how do companies
generate repeat sales of luxury items
easy they prey on our rabid consumerism
you don't have the new iPhone or Samsung
what are you a caveman if you look at
the specs not much has changed but for
some reason everyone has to have the
latest shiniest thousand-dollar phone so
you buy it to fit in this is what big
corporations do they make you feel cheap
or old-fashioned for not buying the
latest and greatest thing when just a
year ago your phone was the latest and
greatest and will continue to be a great
phone for at least a few more years this
is perceived obsolescence and it's
really our own fault we allow ourselves
to be manipulated into thinking we're
less valuable members of society if
we're not actively engaged in mindless
consumerism you have a car from 2014 how
is that thing still running your TV
isn't 4k HDR how can you stand looking
at that it's an endless cycle maybe we
deserve this consumerist hell we've
enabled but then again maybe the
corporation's should make the greener
choice and start producing products with
more longevity after all every tablet
and cartridge or razor blade we throw
away contributes to the trash heaps and
toxic waste dumps steadily growing
around the world all this said while
planned obsolescence can be seen as a
kind of exploitative practice it's not
completely negative inexpensive and
replaceable products have given people
of all income levels access to more
Goods than would have been possible in
the past we live lives that are much
more convenient and comfortable thanks
to affordable products even if they
aren't built to last a lifetime
it also provides jobs in manufacturing
giving workers the means to make a
living and contribute to society think
of all the small companies making phone
accessories millions of phone cases
screen protectors and countless other
knickknacks keep these companies afloat
and profitable even things like smart
phones can be excused for the most part
at least because whether we like it or
not the technology is improving on at
least a yearly basis which leads to more
powerful and capable devices sure Apple
and Samsung make a killing on their
flagship phones but most of the
technology is available in less
expensive devices which benefits the
consumers who aren't willing to shell
out $1000 on the top-of-the-line model
even if the battery stops holding a
charge in three years the savvy consumer
will just buy a newer model once the
prices dropped making the hassle of
replacing a battery irrelevant positives
and negatives aside this overly
consumerist culture might be on its way
out some smartphone manufacturers are
working on modular or easily repairable
devices ride-sharing services are
incredibly popular and some modern cars
like those from Tesla are fairly
future-proof thanks to over-the-air
software updates even car ownership may
become a thing of the past as fleets of
self-driving vehicles become available
for instant rental we may start to see a
dramatic shift in perspectives on
ownership in the coming years
whatever your purchasing habits just be
aware that yes planned obsolescence is a
thing
but not in all cases and it's not always
necessarily a bad thing and no matter
how often you replace your smartphone
and laptop you can rest easy knowing
that your valuable personal data is
always secure with dashlane the new and
improved dashlane is more than just a
multi device password manager even
though it does do that really well
it also offers a super secure VPN to
keep your browsing absolutely safe no
ads no data collection and easy access
to the peace of mind that can only come
from 100% secure browsing dashlane also
offers dark web monitoring a service
that scans the web for any leaked
personal data and sends you alerts so
you can take immediate action to protect
your
the kind of data usually targeted
includes things like usernames and
passwords credit card numbers social
security numbers phone numbers and
postal and IP addresses
thanks to dark web monitoring you never
have to worry about that again
- Lane's dark web service scans more
than 12 billion records attached to
hacks and data breaches with almost a
million new records added every day try
out these awesome new features by
signing up for the 30-day free trial of
dashlane premium and if you really want
to get serious about online security use
the coupon code second thought to get
10% off your subscription
[Music]
[Music]